have you seen the movie minority report
if you have
you remember its chilling portrayal of a
world where three psychics called
pre-cogs are able to predict future acts
and as a result you can be arrested for
the murder you're about to commit not
the one you've already committed
they
whoever they are
know what you're going to do before you
even do it
married to that
is a universal identification system
using retina scans
that links to a giant database that
remembers everything about you
when you go into a store the holographic
welcomers happily chirp welcome back mr
rosensweig will you be looking for
another pair of shoes today
they also know everything you've ever
done in your life
you really do have a permanent record
the image is
in a word horrifying
it portrays a world where everything
about you is known and where your future
actions can be predicted with accuracy
it's the world of george orwell's 1984
made real by advanced technology
now it's a myth of course
but nobody is sure for how much longer
today we call this phenomenon the
problem of big data
every click you take in cyberspace can
be tracked
your cell phone broadcasts your geo
location constantly
and all your purchases and phone calls
are catalogued somewhere
taken together this information can be
analyzed to paint a picture of you
one that increasingly others can see
and the result is a loss of privacy
in today's lecture we begin a two-part
discussion of how this is happening and
what it means
in this first lecture i want to mostly
tell you about the idea of big data and
show you some examples of how it works
in the next lecture we'll talk about
privacy laws and how we might go about
reclaiming some privacy for ourselves
so what exactly do we mean by big data
in an increasingly networked world
personal information is widely collected
and widely available
as the storehouse of data has grown
so have governmental and commercial
efforts to use this personal data for
their own purposes
commercial enterprises target ads and
solicit new customers
governments use the data to for example
identify and target previously unknown
terror suspects to find what are called
clean skins who are not in any
intelligence database
we have discovered that we can link
together individual bits of data to
build a picture of a person that is more
detailed than the individual parts
if you want a way of thinking about this
think of a tile mosaic or a pointless
painting by saran
each bit of color by itself isn't much
but you put them all together and you
can see a complete picture
we call this growth in the amount of
data available married to the increase
in analytical capability the phenomena
of big data
now clearly big data offers all kinds of
opportunities to those who have access
to it
yet this new capability also comes at a
price
the peril of creating an inerratical
trove of information about innocent
individuals
if the government collects data to build
a picture of
say an unknown terrorist threat
it can also if it's minded to use it to
build a picture of its political
opponents
that sort of use of cyberspace poses
threats both in america
and perhaps even more so in
authoritarian nations abroad
in thinking about this capability and
the opportunities and threats it
presents
we sometimes talk out of both sides of
our mouths
back in 2004 for example there was a
significant hype surrounding the most
ambitious of these new big data programs
the total information awareness program
which was known as tia
tia was a research program initiated by
the defense advanced research projects
agency or darpa in the immediate
aftermath of september 11.
the concept was to use advanced data
analytical techniques to search the
information space of commercial and
public sector data
looking for threat signatures that were
indicative of a terrorist threat
because it would have given the
government access to vast quantities of
data about individuals it was condemned
as the harbinger of big brother and
eventually killed
compare that condemnation
with the universal criticism of the
government for its failure to connect
the dots during the christmas 2009
bombing plot attempt by umar farooq
abdulmutallab
in that case we were it is said not
doing enough data analysis not linking
nsa intercepts to state department
reporting or to travel records
so that conflict gives you some idea of
the cross currents that are at play here
the conundrum arises because the
analytical techniques are fundamentally
similar to those used by traditional law
enforcement agencies taking a lead and
finding connections but they operate on
a much more vast set of data and that
data is much more readily capable of
analysis and manipulation
as a result
the differences in degree
tend to become differences in kind
to put this issue in perspective
just consider a partial listing of
relevant databases that might be
targeted
credit cards telephone calls
criminal records
real estate purchases
travel itineraries
and so on
the technological reality is that
all of that information is available
somewhere in cyberspace
and it's easy for others to access
even though the average citizen probably
thinks that his or her credit card
records and web serving habits are
private
this is a fundamental change
caused by technological advances that
like king knuts fabled tide cannot be
stopped or slowed
the phenomenon derives from two related
yet distinct trends
increases in computing power and
decreases in data storage costs
most of you have seen with your own eyes
the steady increase in the power of
computers
it's best expressed in moore's law named
after intel computer science scientist
gordon moore who first articulated the
law back in 1965
moore's law predicts that computer chip
capacities will double every 18 to 24
months
moore's law has been remarkably accurate
for nearly 30 years the effect of
routine doubling is so great that we
have to graph it logarithmically where
each step up the y-axis shows an
increase by a factor of 10.
in practice
what this means is that processor
capacity today
is more than a million times greater
than in 1970.
the power of this processing capacity
translates almost directly into
processing speed
it is what drives the information
technology tools that power google and
amazon and what makes walmart's
purchasing system a reality
and though no one predicts that
processing speed will double
indefinitely
surely that's a physical impossibility
there is no current expectation that the
limits of chip capacity have been
reached
married to this trend is another one the
remarkable reduction in the costs of
data storage
data storage costs have also been
decreasing at a logarithmic rate almost
identical to the increases we've
experienced in chip capacity but in the
exact opposite direction
what this means in practical terms
is that while in 1984 it cost roughly
200
to store a megabyte of data
by 1999
that cost had sunk to 75 cents
and today you can buy 100 megabytes of
data storage capacity for a penny
on ebay you can frequently purchase a
terabyte storage device for your desktop
for less than a hundred dollars
a terabyte is roughly one trillion bytes
of data
a huge volume for storing simple
alphanumeric information
here too the prospects are forever
cheaper data storage
one can readily imagine peta or even
exabyte size personal storage devices
a petabyte is one million gigabytes an
exabyte is one billion gigabytes
in 2009 the entire internet was roughly
500 exabytes of data
yet within 10 years or so
that storage capacity may be available
to a small corporation
so just imagine what a large corporation
or a government could purchase and
maintain
therefore the story of technology today
requires us to answer the question
what happens when ever quicker
processing power meets ever cheaper
storage capacity
anyone who uses gmail knows the answer
to that question
no longer do you have to laboriously
label file and tag your email in order
to find it again
you now simply
store all the email you want to retain
and you use a simple natural language
search algorithm to pull up relevant
emails from storage when needed
the storage cost of gmail to the user is
zero google offers it for free
and the processing time for any search
request for the average individual is
measured in at most seconds
so here is how former ibm chairman
samuel j palmisano put it in a speech he
gave in september 2011.
quote
we're all aware of the approximately two
billion people now on the internet in
every part of the planet thanks to the
explosion of mobile technology but there
are also upwards of a trillion
interconnected and intelligent objects
and organisms what we call the internet
of things
all of this is generating vast stores of
information
it is estimated that there will be 44
times as much data and content coming
over the next decade really reaching
35 zettabytes in 2020. a zettabyte is a
one followed by 21 zeros
and thanks to advanced computation
analytics we can now make sense of that
data in something like real time
this enables very different kinds of
insights foresight and decision making
now our law and policy thinking hasn't
caught up with this reality yet
ten years ago surveying the technology
of the time which
by and large was a hundred times less
powerful than today's data processing
capacity
scott mcneely who is then ceo of sun
microsystems said quote privacy is dead
get over it
what he was describing was the loss of
public anonymity
the ability to act
whether physically or in cyberspace
without anyone having the technological
capacity to permanently record and
retain data about your activity for
later analysis
american law actually has a phrase to
describe this phenomenon
it's practical obscurity
derived from a 1989 supreme court case
department of justice versus reporters
committee the origin of the phrase is
instructive in illuminating the effects
of the change in technology
back in the late 1980s practically at
the dawn of time for computers the
department of justice went to a great
deal of trouble to create a database
with information about the criminal
records of known offenders
at the time those types of records were
kept in lots of disparate databases that
were not connected to each other
arrest records might be held by a local
police station
charging charging records by a district
attorney and disposition and sentencing
records by a state court
federal records were of course held by
still other law enforcement authorities
attorneys and courts
all of these records were generally
public
and in theory available for inspection
by the press or private citizens
but in practice the records were so
widely scattered among so many data
holders that no newspaper or individual
could incur the expense of finding all
the information and creating a
comprehensive dossier on any individual
they were in a phrase
practically obscure
only the federal government had the
degree of need and adequacy of resources
to undertake the task of creating at
great expense the precursor of what is
today the national crime information
center
at very great cost the department of
justice began the collection of criminal
records on a small number of criminals
mostly prominent mafiadons who were of
national interest
the reporters committee case was a
powerful expression of the strength of
the paradigm of practical obscurity
a cbs news correspondent and a press
organization filed a freedom of
information act request with the
department of justice
asking for the collated dossier or the
rap sheet on alleged mafia figures
their reasoning was to me quite
persuasive
since the information was all public
when found in the disparate databases it
did not lose that public character when
collected by the federal government
and if it was public information then it
was clearly subject to disclosure under
the freedom of information act known as
foia
the department denied the foia request
and a unanimous supreme court whose
membership at the time included jurists
ranging from liberal justice william
brennan to conservative justice william
rehnquist approved the denial
according to the court quote
plainly there is a vast difference
between the public records that might be
found after a diligent search of
courthouse files county archives and
local police stations throughout the
country and a computerized summary
located in a single clearing house of
information
end quote because of that difference the
court concluded that the quote privacy
interest in maintaining the practical
obscurity of rap sheet information will
always be high
today
the court's confident assertion that
obscurity will always be high has proven
to have a half-life of less than 20
years
large data collection and aggregation
companies with names like
experian and choice point
hire retirees to harvest by hand public
records from government databases
paper records are digitized and
electronic records are downloaded
these data aggregation companies
typically hold birth records credit and
conviction records real estate
transactions and liens
bridal registries and even kennel club
records
one company axiom
estimates that it holds on average
approximately 1500 pieces of data on
each adult american
that's you
since most
though not all of these records are
governmental in origin the government
has equivalent access to the data and
what they cannot create themselves they
can likely buy or demand from the
private sector
the day is now here where anyone with
enough data and sufficient computing
power can develop a detailed picture of
any identifiable individual
the picture might tell your food
preferences or your underwear size
it might tell something about your
politics or your friend's friends
politics
remember the 1993 new yorker cartoon by
peter steiner that we talked about in
lecture three
the one that depicted a dog seated at a
computer and telling a fellow canine on
the internet nobody knows you're a dog
well
today as one observer has said they not
only know you're a dog
but they know your favorite leash color
and whether or not you've been neutered
it's all in some pervasive database
somewhere
so what does all this mean in practice
and
how does it work
these systems of data analysis
are remarkably technologically
sophisticated
they are in the end an attempt to sift
through large quantities of personal
information to identify subjects whose
identities are not known or in the
commercial context
these individuals are called potential
customers
in the world of global activism they
might be called anonymous or russian
patriotic hackers
in the terrorism context they're often
called clean skins individuals who are
dangerous because nothing is known of
their predilections
for precisely this reason this form of
data analysis is sometimes called
knowledge discovery
as the intention is to discover
something previously unknown about an
individual or group of individuals
so let me give you a few examples to
illustrate the point
probably the best place to start is with
the 9 11 attacks by now everyone has
heard that they happened because we
couldn't connect the dots
but what exactly does that mean
well
at bottom it means that the government
didn't use big data
here's how it should have worked but
didn't
in short
as a department of defense review
committee concluded with just seven
clicks of the mouse through existing
public databases
all 19 terrorists could have been
identified and linked to each other
two of the terrorists made reservations
on american airlines flight 77
their names were also on the cia's watch
list for terrorists in the united states
but we didn't connect those two pieces
of information
if we had we would have learned that the
two addresses they gave to the airline
and a simple cross check would have
found three other terrorists including
the infamous muhammad atta who also made
reservations for flights on september
11th and who also used those two
addresses
now if we also cross check the callback
phone numbers that otta gave to the
airlines
we would have found another five
terrorists who gave the same phone
number to the reservation agents and
also made flight reservations for
september 11th
yet another terrorist would have been
identified because he used the same
frequent flyer number as one of the
other men on the list
and two more were in public databases
like the yellow pages and listed as
sharing living arrangements with one of
the terrorists
finally the remaining six terrorists
could have been identified by links to a
different list
the u.s immigration and naturalization
services expired visa illegal entry list
one of those terrorists was on the list
and the other five had public records of
having lived with him or with each other
and all of course shared this common
characteristic of making reservations on
flights for the morning of september
11th
in short
as a department of defense review
committee concluded with just seven
clicks of the mouse through existing
public databases
all 19 terrorists could have been
identified and linked to each other
the story of raid albania
a jordanian who attempted to enter enter
the united states at chicago's o'hare
airport on june 14 2003 is another
powerful illustration of how big data
can be used
and this time it was a success
in some ways it shows how much changed
in just two years
albania was probably a clean skin a
terrorist with no known record at all he
was carrying a valid business visa in
his jordanian passport and on the
surface appeared to be an unremarkable
business traveler from the middle east
the department of homeland security
operates a sophisticated data analysis
program called the automated targeting
system or ats to assess the comparative
risks of arriving passengers
they use ats to decide who to stop and
talk to and who to let through easily
the system is essential given the sheer
volume of travelers to america in a
typical year approximately 350 million
people cross american borders
more than 85 million of those arrived by
air
since over 350 million individuals
cannot obviously be subject to intense
scrutiny
some form of assessment and analysis
must be used to make choices about how
and when to conduct inspections
ats is that system
ats flagged albania for heightened
scrutiny he was pulled from the main
line of entrance at o'hare and
individually questioned
during the interview
albania's answers were inconsistent and
evasive
so much so that the u.s customs and
border protection officer who conducted
the interview decided to deny his
application for entry and ordered him
return to his origin point
as a matter of routine albania's
photograph and fingerprints were
collected before he was sent on his way
now there this story might have ended
since cbp officers reject entry
applications daily for a host of reasons
but albania proved an unusual case
more than a year later in february 2005
a car filled with explosives drove into
a crowd of military and police recruits
in the town of hillah iraq
more than 125 people died
the largest death toll for a single
incident in iraq until that time
the suicide bombers hand and forearm
were found chained to the steering wheel
of the exploded car
why they were chained as a fascinating
question of psychology
when the fingerprints were taken by u.s
military forces a match was found to the
fingerprints taken from albania 20
months earlier in chicago
most similar successes are not made
public
often the factors that form part of the
analysis cannot be revealed and success
in identifying
terrorist suspects or in other context
members of a criminal organization would
be negated by disclosure of the success
only albania's death made his case fit
for public disclosure
so now let's change our focus from
counter-terrorism
to the power of big data to reveal
personal information and patterns
david mccandless of london created a
chart based on research which used
sophisticated computer programs to scour
the web and scrape bits of data from a
lot of sources
for obvious reasons we call these web
crawling programs spiders
mccandless's chart represents hundreds
of thousands of data points displayed
graphically
it represents an annual human activity
and it shows a large peak in spring
and another peak towards the end of the
year
so what is this activity
why don't you take a guess
i'll tell you some things that it's not
for example it's not the frequency with
which we watch sporting events even
though the college basketball march
madness and fall football seasons occur
near the time of the activity peaks
it's not greeting card buying either
though the peaks are near easter and
christmas
so what is it
what is a human activity that occurs
most frequently in march and then again
around the thanksgiving christmas
holiday season in the u.s
if you want pause the lecture for a
second to think about it and then start
it up again when you want to continue
go ahead
we'll wait for you
ready
here's the answer
facebook breakup data
it's a graph about how love ends at
least among facebook users the big peaks
are for spring break and the holidays
there are even small peaks on mondays
since people usually break up over the
weekend and report it to their facebook
friends on monday
this is pretty amazing stuff
it's really knowledge discovery a
pattern we would not see without big
data
it's kind of exciting
or from a different viewpoint maybe
disturbing
and it's also why facebook is worth
billions of dollars
they are collecting information about
you that you voluntarily provide and
using it to build a picture of who you
are
that picture is worth money to them and
to other people
i don't know about you
but to me it's sometimes a little spooky
how accurate the google ads are that
show up on my system they really do seem
to know what i'm thinking
so let's try another example
i have a little program on my computer
called collusion
you can run it on your own computer if
you want provided you use firefox as
your web browser
what the program does is simply watch as
you browse the web and then keep track
of how your browsing habits are being
collected
see what you probably don't know is that
when you go to a particular website well
say google
that website shares your visit with lots
of other websites
it colludes with them if you will to
build a better picture of who you are
a snapshot of my own recent web browsing
shows a field of dots
each one representing a different
website
if i hover over the dot that represents
google i can see that google shares my
browsing history with more than 20 other
websites
some of those like facebook are other
sites that i actually use
but several of them like hot air and
daily caller are places i never go
and there are even some like cornell.edu
that make me wonder
i have absolutely no idea why they're
connected to google
but there you go
this picture is a graphic example of how
my personal web browsing history is
being converted into information about
me
so ask yourself this
did you realize how much of your
browsing history is public
did you know that the places you go
actually broadcast that fact to other
folks on the web
you can see how that too is
a bit creepy
of course in other contexts what seems
only a bit creepy can become pretty
scary and downright authoritarian
here's a final example
your cell phone is constantly reporting
your location to the nearest cell towers
that's how the system knows where you
are so it can connect a call to you
when i go to visit my grandchildren in
evanston illinois my cell phone checks
in with the local cell towers and so the
cell service provider knows that i'm not
near my home in washington dc
that's a perfectly sensible idea
otherwise cell phone service wouldn't
work
but the company keeps those records of
where your cell phone is and that means
they know not only where you are but
where you've been
a german politician created a video from
his cell phone records that shows a
six-month log of all his movements
he put it together to make a point
because most of where we go is innocuous
but if i have six months of your travel
logs i'll know if you're a church-goer
or a gym fanatic or if you visit local
porn shops
they say that you are what you eat
but really and truly you are where you
visit
now maybe you're not worried that your
phone company knows all this
but what if they sell it to some
commercial advertiser or what if the
government issues a subpoena and
collects all those records
the issue is highly contentious right
now and we'll talk more about it in the
next lecture
but at the present time the miller smith
third party doctrine applies
that's the doctrine that says that
information you share with a third party
like facebook or your phone provider is
not protected by the fourth amendment
and that means that you have no privacy
interest in the location data that you
voluntarily broadcast to the cell phone
company
that's a pretty odd definition of
voluntary to be sure
but there it is
and so that's our introduction to the
world of big data and how your actions
are being watched in cyberspace
whether we like it or not the phenomena
is here to stay
the only question is when and how we can
monitor and control the use of these
techniques so that we get the benefits
of the growth in data and analytics
without the potential harms to privacy
and civil liberties
how we can do that is the subject of our
next lecture
[Music]
do
[Music]